LYNNE MURPHY: I am from
upstate New York.
CGP GREY: I'm from downstate
New York.
LYNNE MURPHY: I live now
in Brighton, England.
CGP GREY: And I live
in London now.
BRADY HARAN: So how long have
you been in the UK?
LYNNE MURPHY: 13 years.
CGP GREY: So I've been living
here for 10 years.
And I've spent a lot of that
time working as a physics
teacher in secondary schools.
LYNNE MURPHY: So if you're
giving somebody your phone
number or your credit card
number, and you've got two
numbers in a row that
are the same.
So my number is 8844
in my office.
The British way to say that
would be double 8, double 4.
And it would have never
occurred to me
to say it that way.
CGP GREY: I don't know about
Americans in general.
But I can say that for me, when
I moved to London, I was
really thrown by the
double numbers
thing for quite a while.
LYNNE MURPHY: I would
say 8, 8, 4, 4.
I might say 88, 44.
But I wouldn't say double
8, double 4.
CGP GREY: When I moved here,
there were two problems.
One is the double
numbers thing.
And the second thing is that
people say the telephone
numbers in a different pattern
than they do US numbers.
So it was that different
pattern, plus people saying
things like double
5, double 9.
I had such a hard time getting
those numbers the first time.
And maybe I'm just particularly
slow.
LYNNE MURPHY: The thing that
always trips me up is I don't
know whether to say triple
when I get three of those
things in a row.
So if I had a credit card that
had three 0's in a row, do I
say triple 0?
Do I say double 0, 0?
Do I say 0, double 0?
Do I say 0, 0, 0?
I don't know what to say.
I'd love to hear from British
people, some instruction on
how to read my credit
card number.
CGP GREY: Off the top of my
head, I can't think of having
ever heard triple, but I
wouldn't rule it out.
I don't actually know.
Perhaps your commenters
can let us
know if they say triple.
LYNNE MURPHY: Another example
is what happens when you use
numbers in the thousands, or
numbers with four digits.
The president's address--
that's called 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue in American.
And I think most British people
would be comfortable
with that being sixteen
hundred.
But when you get to a bigger
number, Americans are happy to
say that is fifty-three
hundred.
A British person would probably
call this five
thousand three hundred here.
CGP GREY: Where I grew up on
downstate New York, pretty
much everybody around me would
say fifty-three hundred.
Like for example, I know that
my parents will say
fifty-three hundred.
But for me as a kid, I always
found that a confusing way to
phrase that.
There's something about
it that just
doesn't jell in my mind.
And honestly, it took me years
and years to really get that.
And so in my mind, when I hear
someone say something like
seventy-two hundred, I have to
kind of think about it in
terms of $100 bills.
So again, if someone says
fifty-three hundred, I have to
visualize 53 $100 bills
on a table.
For me, I always consciously
made an effort to say five
thousand three hundred instead
of fifty-three hundred.
BRADY HARAN: Which do you
think is more elegant?
Fifty-three hundred or five
thousand three hundred?
LYNNE MURPHY: Well, five
thousand three hundred is
easier to understand.
I mean, when I say fifty-three
hundred, I get confused myself
whether I mean 5,300
or 53,000.
CGP GREY: Even though I think
that fifty-three hundred is
linguistically nicer--
it sort of rolls off the
tongue more easily--
but I like the precision
in saying five
thousand three hundred.
But I was definitely going
against the tide of people
that I lived around.
LYNNE MURPHY: Nevertheless,
I find it easy to say.
When I'm thinking of numbers,
when I want to say how much
something costs.
CGP GREY: You deal with
$100 bills in America.
Like, it's not rare to come
across $100 bills.
Whereas I don't think
there are--
now, I'm not 100% sure.
But I don't think that there are
100-pound notes that are
actually produced.
I think it stops at 50.
And I have only incredibly
rarely in my life, ever seen
someone actually use
a 50-pound note.
And it's always remarkable.
Like at a bank, I'll see
someone pull out a 50.
So maybe that's why as an
American, it's easier to think
in terms of amounts of
$100 bills, right?
I have 12 $100 bills.
So that's twelve hundred.
I don't know if that has
anything to do with it.
But that might be why British
people are not as comfortable
with that kind of phrasing.
LYNNE MURPHY: The second year of
the 2000s was two thousand
one, in American speech,
generally.
But in British speech,
that sounds weird.
That sounds American.
You'd say two thousand
and one.
So two thousand one, two
thousand and one.
CGP GREY: This is one of those
cases where, having lived in
London for 10 years, and in
particular, having taught in
front of classes and being
very used to speaking to
British people all the time, I
can sometimes kind of forget
these little phrases,
and which way have
I always said it.
And just naturally thinking
about it, the two thousand and
one or two thousand one--
which way would I have said
it when I was in New York?
I'm not 100% sure.
I think I would've said two
thousand one, but it's one of
those things that gets kind of
lost when you move from one
country to another.
Sometimes those little things
can just kind of--
you just become uncertain
about how it was.
And then you feel like a
crazy person, right?
You feel like, I should know how
I used to say things, but
you just lose it.
But I did look up, after you
mentioned that the two
thousand and one--
I wanted to see how
Arthur C. Clarke
actually says that number.
ARTHUR C. CLARKE: Of course,
"Two Thousand and One"--
CGP GREY: He's British, and he
says in interviews-- he says
"Two Thousand and One" as the
title for his book is the way
he always phrased it.
I tried to find some audio of
Stanley Kubrick saying the
title of the movie.
But he's an incredibly secretive
kind of guy and
didn't do very many interviews
about it.
And so I was unable to find any
clip of Stanley Kubrick
actually speaking aloud the
name of perhaps his most
famous movie.
LYNNE MURPHY: If you want to
count out seconds, which
people sometimes need to do, a
typical way of doing this is
to have a word that you put in
between your numbers to make
it long enough that you've
got a full second
between the two numbers.
And the typical way to do this
in American English, or a
typical way to do it is to
use the word Mississippi.
So 1 Mississippi, 2 Mississippi,
3 Mississippi.
CGP GREY: 4 Mississippi, 5
Mississippi, 6 Mississippi.
LYNNE MURPHY: Hopefully,
it's about a second.
I've never actually tested it.
CGP GREY: I have no idea where
it comes from, except that
it's a fun word to say.
And it's long, so that seems
like an obvious choice to go
in the middle.
LYNNE MURPHY: Another way to do
it is 1, one thousand, 2,
one thousand, which you'll
notice has a different number
of syllables.
The 1, one thousand, 2, one
thousand I think is found in
both America and Britain.
But then in Britain, you've
got other ones, like 1
Piccadilly, 2 Piccadilly, 3
Piccadilly, or 1 elephant, 2
elephant, 3 elephant.
CGP GREY: I was trying to think
about this, and I don't
think I've ever had the
opportunity to hear any of my
students count in this kind of
way that you would do, where
you're intentionally
doing seconds.
So I don't know what any of
them would have said.
But you asking me about this
is basically the first time
I've ever heard about Piccadilly
or elephant.
LYNNE MURPHY: When I said 1
Mississippi, 2 Mississippi,
that's how I learned it, with
that very specific, sing-song
kind of rhythm to help you
count out the seconds.
And because I've only done this
on the blog, I've not
actually heard people say 1
Piccadilly, 2 Piccadilly.
I'm not quite sure how
they're singing it.
CGP GREY: Piccadilly
I think is OK.
It has that same kind of rhythm
as Mississippi, right?
So 1 Mississippi, 2 Piccadilly,
3 elephant.
Elephant does not work.
I don't think that
works at all.
1 elephant, 2 elephant--
it's so clunky.
It's no good at all.
I have to veto that one, but
Piccadilly, Piccadilly seems
incredibly similar
to Mississippi.
So I'm perfectly happy with
that as a difference.
LYNNE MURPHY: But it's also the
kind of thing that I've
found people have family
versions of that aren't used
anywhere outside their
extended families.
There's room for lots
of variation.
BRADY HARAN: We want to hear
what word you put in between
numbers when you count,
to make sure
there's a second spacing.
So put comments under
the video.
Mississippi, elephant,
Piccadilly, thousand,
something different?
We want to know.
LYNNE MURPHY: People often ask
me, or express astonishment
when they get American addresses
that they need to
send something to.
And the address might be four
or five digits long, the
number before the street.
So to live at 2787
Main Street, or
something like that.
Whereas the last place I lived
here was number 7, and my
mother always found
that strange.
She often wrote it as 70.
She just couldn't imagine that I
really lived at a place that
was only number 7 in the
great scheme of things.
CGP GREY: It's funny, because I
never really tuned into the
low house numbers thing.
I mean, now that you have
mentioned it, it seems
incredibly obvious.
And yes, I can think of a bunch
of addresses in my life
here that were low numbers.
And it's definitely the case--
well, at least it's the case
in New York growing up that I
don't think there was ever a
house number that was
less than 100.
So I knew people who lived in
100, or 107, or 109 houses,
but I don't think there was ever
a single address that was
below that number.
LYNNE MURPHY: Where I'm from,
you never have a single digit.
You rarely have a two-digit
street address.
So my family is on the first
block of Miller Street, and
the first number is 100.
Well, it's about the grid
road system in America.
In England, you don't talk about
blocks the same way you
do in America, because
the roads are all
higgledy-piggledy and don't
necessarily make nice squares.
But since American ones
typically do make nice
squares, what you want in the
system is to have the numbers
all match within each block.
You talk about the 100 block
of Miller Street.
Once you cross the road that
intersects with Miller Street
and go on to the next block,
it'll be the 200 block.
So my block of my street where
I grew up goes up to 131.
And then it starts over at 200
once you cross the road.
BRADY HARAN: So your numbers
get higher quicker.
LYNNE MURPHY: Yeah.
CGP GREY: It is almost
unbelievable to me that the
numbers on one side of the
street don't have anything to
do with the numbers on the
other side of the street.
And I still come across this,
and it's just appalling--
right?
That you're walking across the
street, and the numbers on one
side are going 3, 5, 7, 9.
And you look across the other
side of the street, and the
numbers will be 50,
48, 46, right?
They're even, they're not
aligned, and they're going in
the opposite direction and
it's just maddening.
I don't understand how this came
to be, why anybody has
let it stand for as
long as it has.
It is just baffling to me.
And the first few times that I
ran across this, that I didn't
realize, like, you have to check
the numbers on the other
side of the street, I got
severely lost in London a
couple of times, trying
to find places.
Because I'm walking down very
long streets in the completely
opposite direction, thinking,
oh, I'll just cross the street
when I need those even
numbers, right?
And then you get to wherever
you're supposed to be, you
cross the street.
And you're hundreds off from
wherever you were actually
trying to get.
But you're still on
the same street.
It's just unbelievable to me.
It's like, I refuse to believe
that humans ever decided to do
this on purpose.
This isn't exactly number
related, but I can tell you
the thing that I did notice,
that I find is just charming,
is the habit of naming buildings
"houses." So even
like, a giant office building
will sometimes have a name.
And it'll be like,
70 Darwin House.
But this house suffix, or this
house label for, like, big
corporate buildings, or just
council flats, I find is kind
of remarkable and very charming
in and of itself.
That strikes me as being very
British, where someone could
say, oh, I live at
50 Feinman House.
But 50 Feinman House is a
gigantic tower block, right?
It's not like a little cottage,
like it sounds.
So I do quite like that.
I love to explore the city and
just kind of wander around.
And there's always a ton of
construction going on.
And in particular, in the past
few years and right now,
there's a bunch of big, luxury
buildings going up, or that
have been recently
constructed.
And I can't help but notice that
all of them want to be
number one at whatever
they are.
So for example, there's 1 London
Bridge, and there's 1
Blackfriar's, there's
1 Tower Bridge.
And these are luxury
buildings.
And they always write it
really big on the sign.
It'll say 1 Blackfriar's.
And the other thing that I can't
help but notice is they
always like to write
out the one.
It's O-N-E. It's never
the number 1.
I find that interesting.
I assume that somewhere, some
architecture firm decided that
this is a kind of luxury
statement.
I'd be curious to know
if this happens
elsewhere in the world.
Because as we discussed, I don't
think that it can happen
in New York, because
the buildings
can't start at 1, right?
They have to start at 100.
But I've noticed that some of
these buildings that label
themselves as 1 whatever--
they're in suspicious spots.
Where I look around and I think,
I'm not sure that you
can really claim that you
are 1 Tower Bridge.
There are numerous buildings
here, any of which looks like
they could be number
1 Tower Bridge.
So I have my doubts
about the accuracy
of this number system.
Although with the street
numbers, who knows, right?
The numbers don't have anything
to do with anything,
so they could just be
all over the place.
-So a man walks into a bar.
He asks for 10 times more drinks
than everyone else.
The barman says, now that is
an order of magnitude.